hey youtubers you guys have been asking
me for an endgame video so this is going
to be all about bran stark versus the
night king sort of diametric opposite
drawing on the same type of power so
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
there's a new round for the HBO now
subscriptions to all yesa do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so originally this was just going
to be a video about the night king
bringing down the wall but then I
realized that you have to get into a lot
of the history of how the wall was
created brand time-travel theories it is
sort of spiraled into more of a brand
night king video so this is more of a
detailed analysis of their magics and
how they'll be battling each other in
brands role in season 7 as it applies to
the night king making it south of the
wall so we start with the idea that the
night king now has the ability to make
it south of the wall the idea during
season six was that brand helped break
the enchantment that prevented him from
getting into the three-eyed Ravens
weirwood so that's a bit of a hat tip to
him breaking the enchantment on the wall
the whole reason for the walls creation
the books say that the wall was created
between 8,000 and 6,000 years ago I
think really they started building it
about 8,000 years ago and then it just
took a long time to complete
it's almost 350 miles long there's no
way that they would complete that
overnight even if they had the help of
the Giants to construct it or from
someone like bran or someone with the
powers of the three-eyed Raven we know
now because of the season 6 flashback
that the children of the forest are the
ones that created the night king in the
others to fight the first men because
about 12,000 years ago the first men
invaded the children started to lose cut
to about 2,000 years later they finally
signed the pact but now based on what
the show has told us now we know that
that pact was probably signed in haste
so that the first men and the children
of the force would band together to stop
the others that they had just created
whether or not they killed that night
King because it sounds like a lot of the
children of the forest powers are the
powers of the three-eyed Raven so if the
Bloodraven can transfer his power to
brand that it also stands to reason the
night king can transfer his power to
another white Walker or to someone else
so the George RR Martin's comments about
the mythical Knights
the 13th Lord Commander make more sense
so there's a story that old man tells
about a Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch someone of stark blood who went
north of the wall and fell in love with
someone who looked a lot like another is
implied by the story that they did the
deed and he was converted into a white
Walker or the new night king then they
took the night for it and sort of
turning other brothers until they were
put down by an alliance of the wildlings
of the time and the start king at the
time so when people asked George are
Martin is that Knights King the mythical
one the same one that we saw in the TV
show and he said no that person is no
more still alive than the mythical
figures that started each of the big
households like land the clever who
started House Lannister brand takes in
all the knowledge in the powers of the
three-eyed raven these new knight kings
taken the power and knowledge of the old
knight kings so even if an epic alliance
of everyone in Westeros is able to take
down the knight King and the army of the
dead there's always the chance that
another one could come back but there
are all kinds of myths about the
enchantments in the walls we only know
that there is magic that just keeps the
knight King and the others from passing
through because there is more than one
way to get around the wall they prove
that during season 3 when they climbed
over it but by Martin's explanation
that's what keeps the knight King from
just climbing right over it or from
burrowing beneath it the enchantment is
just sort of extends in this invisible
field above and below the wall and based
on what we saw at season five during
hardhome the army of the Dead are not
great swimmers otherwise they would have
just rushed the bay and taken down Jon
Snow's forces that they were trying to
leave so even though it would take them
a long time it's not like the night king
could just ride around one of the size
of the wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea or
the other side of the wall there are
devices at Castle black the night for
the other places where you can actually
travel south of the wall through a
tunnel to cave the tunnel in is they
need to do that so even if the
enchantment is broken and the night king
and his army can step right through the
gate they can still slow them down
greatly but at that point the night king
can just have his army of the Dead
excavate the tunnel it will take a
little bit longer but it's much much
easier than sending them climbing
over the top and is amazing as it would
be to see him bring the wall crumbling
down think about that number 350 miles
of a giant wall coming down
simultaneously there's a long list of
ridiculous things the game of Thrones
has tried to pull off that would be one
of the biggest things I think the more
practical explanation is that the night
king could crack the earth crack part of
the wall and structurally weaken it then
send his army through but I'm only
expecting to see part of the wall come
crumbling so like the wall itself could
be rebuilt and repaired the enchantments
could be put back up during the final
season hopefully brand survives the
final season because there will be
someone that he would then either have
to pass his knowledge on to to continue
to watch over the realms of men because
it would sound like the cycle would
restart again that gets into more
endgame theory which is a slightly
different thing because brand in the
night King right now are sort of like
diametric opposites they both draw on
the same magic so if one survives the
other is probably going to survive in
some form to whether or not he passes
his power on to a new night king or
whether he's literally just beaten back
I think the ultimate reward though would
be to see someone actually physically
defeat the night king some situation
where you could actually call a legit
victory okay
this person who's been coming after us
we have killed but we're brand's real
power lives is in fighting the magic of
the night King so the night King is all
about raising the army of the dead we
haven't seen all of his abilities yet
but we've seen him crack the earth we've
seen him control nature and he also has
sort of a presence and the astral plane
where he can sense brand so he can see
through time the same way that bran can
see through time using the weirwoods
getting into actual practical battles
bran does have a lot of control over
nature like the night king do we just
haven't seen yet so in a big fight it's
a lot easier to see the value that
someone like Daenerys has with dragons
you just send them in they scorch the
field they put it in the trailer we see
drogon getting ready to light up a bunch
of Lannister soldiers so it's more of a
area-of-effect weapon of mass
destruction so the thing the knight King
has going for him is that the army of
the Dead grows exponentially for every
person that you take into battle and
they kill their army grows by
one so in a situation like Battle of the
bastards this a giant body pile would
just turn against you instantaneously
you would be automatically screwed this
is where brand comes in you've seen the
night King use area-of-effect raises
where he raises a bunch of dead at the
same time bran has the ability to
neutralize some of that magic he can't
stop the night King because they're
relatively equal in the night King knows
much more about his powers than bran
does he's still figuring things out so
you have an army of the Dead rushing
south of the wall bran could say crack
the earth slow the army down while the
Dragons roast them but he can't stop the
night King for just automatically
raising more dead soldiers back up and
his real power is actually in knowledge
just explaining what's going on reasons
for them to form an alliance and that's
really where the value of season 7 is
isn't that all these people that are at
war in the south need to learn to come
together so that they can fight the
night King the true threat so even
though bran has a lot of amazing visual
powers to fight the night king things
that actually just look really badass on
screen
it sounds like based on what the actors
are saying most of season 7 will be him
just trying to convey information to
John so look I've seen the truth of
things this is where the night King
comes from this is how we can fight them
these are the tools that we need these
are the other people that you need to
get on your team and even though he's
been stuck in that cave
I'd be willing to bet that brand senses
the power that the Dragons have and even
though he might not know exactly what's
going on with them
he'll sense their power and then
separately you'll have characters just
put two and two together like you see
drogon here The Legend of the Dragons
will spread people will get the idea oh
we have an army of the Dead maybe
they'll come in handy against them so
not everything is going to need a brand
explainer really just the things that
you could only know had you traveled
back into the past one of the few
criticisms of the show though is in sort
of that brand loophole like why doesn't
he know about the Dragons I think of
this is sort of a little finger problem
season five starts little finger has
absolutely zero knowledge of Ramsay
Bolton the way that Aiden Gillen
explained it no he doesn't understand
how terrible Ramsay was when he made
Sansa marry him so that they could get
into Winterfell so the show has
fully dumbed down some characters in
order to set up big plot lines and twist
like a little finger had known exactly
what was up with Ramsay Bolton he
probably would have taken steps to
prevent the things that happened to
Sansa and she wouldn't have experienced
all that trauma so she wouldn't have
gotten her character arc and she
wouldn't be stabby Sansa that we see in
all the season 7 footage so it also
stands to reason that that will also
happen with characters like bran where
it's like well if he knew about the
Dragons ahead of time why didn't he just
automatically reach out to Daenerys
bring them up to the north and take care
of it before the army of the Dead got
too big so let me know what you guys
think about that and how long do you
think it's going to be before brand
fully understands his powers because the
way the show explains that he
effectively downloaded the entire
history of the world as well as a host
of powers without any kind of
instruction manual but we can talk more
about brand specific powers as they
unfold on the show like you'll see him
do things you've never seen him do
before that's why they keep hyping up
the visual effects budget seeing
Daenerys use the dragons and battle
situations that you've read about but
you've never seen before like historical
battles Aegon conquering the Seven
Kingdoms it's sort of like a really big
twist of the last long night giant ice
spiders giant animals that are turned
into whites so leave all your requests
for bonus videos the cast did a big
preview where they talk about each of
their characters I was thinking about
doing a euron greyjoy video next because
he really needs to redeem himself he is
the most evil character on the show
right now next to Cersei in the after
the plays them says some funny things
and there's some context that we have
for a year on and wins a winter that
definitely make him seem like he's going
to be a much more terrible book villain
than TV show villain but hopefully he'll
redeem himself congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner jeff portnoy
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you must be a
Tropic Thunder fan while you wait for my
next video you can click here to learn
about the big Empire Jon Snow true name
debacle and you can click here for all
the other season 7 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight